- steven guilbeault je promets et
déclare solennellement et sincèrement
qu'on mieux de ma compétence et de ma
connaissance j'exécuterai loyalement et
fidèlement les pouvoirs et je
m'inquiéterais des responsabilités qui
m'ont été confiées en qualité de
ministre du patrimoine canadien
mais ce n'est pas là qu'on l'attendait
civile bon bien sûr c'est davantage à
l'environnement dans ses nouvelles
fonctions de ministre don qui sera au
patrimoine au grand désespoir on va le
dire très honnêtement de ses ex
collègues environnementale et s'il est
ce matin dans notre studio
ottawa bonjour monsieur le ministre
bonjour bon dites moi on a parlé tout à
l'heure à bordères il y en a plein
d'autres de vos acolytes leur variété
tous ces gens là ont eu l'impression
d'avoir été d'avoir été roulé deux pas
de perdre un ami je présume que j'irais
pas jusque là mais comprenez vous leur
état d'esprit pourquoi je dirais pas
colère mais un yann rajon ils sont
vraiment pas content je dirais que il y
en a certains qui sont pas contents
effectivement et je leur ai parlé mais
hier soir à ottawa il ya une petite fête
qui était organisé par certes par
d'autres de mes ex collègues écologistes
pour saluer le fait que je faisais mon
arrivée au cabinet du gouvernement
trudeau comme patrick bonnet ou karel
mayrand ou leur mari dell qui sont moins
compte un mois ce que vous savez même
quand j'étais avec eux je t'ai pas
toujours d'accord et y ait jamais été
question gens ne m'a jamais demandé à
être un poste ministériel quelconque
je comprends que certaines personnes
s'était fait à l'idée que ça pourrait
être sommé vous savez une chose que je
dis beaucoup quand j'étais chez les
écologistes et je pense que plusieurs
d'entre eux partagent ce point de vue là
c'est que l'environnement ça doit pas
être la sphère d'une personne autour de
la cam
il faut que ce soit la sphère de
l'ensemble du gouvernement et c'est
vraiment le col on a un ministre
l'environnement qui va être appuyée
autour de la table du conseil des
ministres par plusieurs personnes qui
sont fondamentalement convaincu qu'on
doit faire plus qu'on va faire mieux sur
cette question là je suis certainement
l'une de ces personnes
bon maintenant certains vont dire
j'entendais le premier est dirigé 36
milices de l'environnement derrière moi
bon c'est une belle belle clip là mais
bon il ya madame mécano certainement
mais vous là allez vous pouvoir
discrètement ou en conseil des ministres
comme ce matin dans une heure et demie
faire valoir votre point b est très vert
si vous voulez dans vos propos sans être
exposé sur la scène publique
tout à fait c'est le rôle des membres du
cabinet de s'exprimer de faire valoir
leur point de vue sur l'ensemble des
dossiers qui sont discutées au cabinet
j'ai d'ailleurs déjà parlé avec monsieur
wilkinson de ministres l'environnement
qui soit dit en passant est pas une vis
sur les questions environnementales
il ya travaillé dans le secteur des
technologies propres pendant vingt ans
il était secrétaire parlementaire de la
ministre kenney l'environnement donc
c'est quelqu'un qui a un très bon bagage
et moi je suis convaincu qu'il va faire
un très bon travail et je lui dis que je
serai là pour l'épauler comme catherine
mais qui n'en sera là comme comme
l'ensemble des membres du cabinet
également oui en envoyant monsieur
madame fils-aime danse doit dans l'ouest
occuper de ces dossiers là monsieur on
va pas reculer dans les dossiers de
pipeline
la balance en tant qu on va essayer de
trouver une solution pour pouvoir
utiliser les ressources naturelles
moi ce que je proposerai aux gens de
faire c'est de regarder les engagements
que nous avons pris en campagne sur les
questions environnementales de revoir à
la hausse nos objectifs de paris d'être
carbonneau d'ici 2050 de poursuivre avec
l'électrification d'augmenter les
investissements transport collectif et
je pense que c'est là dessus qu'on doit
être jugé et non pas sur qui quelle
personne et tout autour de la table je
pense que je suis c'est un honneur
immense pour moi coûté à peine six mois
l'idée que je me présente en politique
était seulement sur une idée et je me
retrouve aujourd'hui à la table du
cabinet du gouvernement trudeau dans un
pays du g7 c'est quand même assez
extraordinaire je suis je suis on en rit
j'accepte ça avec beaucoup d'humilité
qu'est-ce que vous amener à la table du
patrimoine canadien dans votre dos dans
votre dans votre porte documents il
avait promis plus de documents
environnementaux et écologiques des que
des documents de de culture ou de
politique culturelle
moi je dirais que là la chose
probablement la plus jeune la plus
importante que que j'apporte au
patrimoine canadien c'est ce que je
m'engage à travailler avec la même
détermination la même énergie la même
conviction que je les fais pour
l'environnement je serai un allié des
artisans de notre culture au québec et
au canada
et oui j'ai beaucoup à apprendre et
c'est ce que je vais faire au cours des
prochaines semaines je vais rencontrer
le plus grand nombre de d'artisans de ce
secteur le possible tant au québec
qu'ailleurs au canada
je voudrais en même temps que je pas
complètement une vis non plus j'ai
publié trois livres jeux devaient
d'ailleurs être au salon du livre de
montréal en fin de semaine en tant
qu'auteur on l'a semble-t-il que je
serai en tant que ministre du patrimoine
canadien
pas exactement du même côté du micro ça
va être ça très bien le jeu serait très
bien alors avec vos briefing book
probablement votre votre caisse de
cartables comme on dirait voilà très
bien merci écouter on se reverra à la
prochaine avec grand plaisir merci marc
andreu